It's a relatively cushy job that seems to
pay pretty well, but that doesn't mean being
a movie star isn't hard work.
Multi-million-dollar productions rely on an
actor's ability to, you know, act, so there's
a lot of pressure for them to do a good job,
And not everyone is great under pressure.
An actor will occasionally, for whatever reason,
forget their lines, and they all flub in different
ways.
They also deal with the embarrassment differently,
and often hilariously.
Here are some famous actors who were caught
messing up their dialogue.
Laurence Fishburne
Bathroom humor is the great human equalizer,
be it the young and the old, the rich and
the poor or the smart and the dumb.
Both Oscar-nominated and non-Oscar nominated
actor alike can get behind a good butt reference.
Which is precisely what happened on the set
of the 2016 science-fiction film Passengers.
In a very wordy scene, Laurence Fishburne,
who plays the spaceship's Chief Deck Officer,
briefs supposed-to-be-hibernating passengers,
Chris Pratt and Jennifer Lawrence, on the
craft's movements.
He ends up giving us a lesson in space anatomy
instead.
"Jupiter.
Uranus.
You name it.
And then along came…"
(laughs)
Bradley Cooper
Messing up lines will usually cause an actor
to break character, laugh, lightly curse,
get back to their mark, and give it another
try.
But some actors are just too cool for that.
(dog licking)
Um... maybe not that cool.
But Hangover actor Bradley Cooper can give
us a master course on what to do when you
flub your lines during a rooftop monologue.
"Whatever happened here may never…" (gibberish)
Just fake it ‘til you make it, even if that
means that you have to speak in gibberish.
Christina Applegate
In Will Ferrell and Adam McKay's Anchorman,
a silly spoof of a horrendously sexist '70s
workplace, Christina Applegate plays the glass
ceiling-shattering news anchor Veronica Corningstone.
She faces open hostility from other members
of the Channel 4 news team, including sports
guy Champ Kind, played by David Koechner and
reporter Brian Fantana, played by Paul Rudd.
"Inside source tells me that the FBI has been
called in to aid in this ongoing investigation."
(curses)
Whammy!
It would be hard for anyone to act under those
circumstances.
Paul Rudd
The comedy films of Judd Apatow maintain an
almost impossible balance between strong,
earnest characters and over-the-top ridiculousness.
The 40-Year-Old Virgin has it's serious and
heartfelt moments, but it's during one of
these that Paul Rudd slips up while pronouncing
the name of a famous painter...
"If you love Trish, you can't do this.
But you gotta finish waxing your chest, because
you look like Edvard Munch's The Scream."
(laughs)
"I can’t do this sorry."
Ben Stiller
It seems like pretty much every romantic comedy
ever made has some variation of the "don't
get on that plane" speech, and the 2004 Ben
Stiller/Jennifer Aniston film Along Came Polly
is no exception.
When it comes time for Stiller to unveil his
true feelings he can't quite remember the
specifics of this particular romantic monologue.
"You go off to Tanzania or Cincinnati or wherever
you're going…
You…
I guarantee you…"
Timothy Dalton
You've got to be smooth in order to play James
Bond, and Timothy Dalton succeeded at being
the ultra-cool super spy for two movies back
in the late 1980s.
Years later, he took on the role of the villain
in the Simon Pegg cop spoof Hot Fuzz, betraying
his 007 image of calm and cool.
"Think they stole the security footage… mother f---
it! I'm sorry."
While that's all mildly amusing, what happened
next was golden...
"Still rolling…" (laughs)
(Curses)
Mila Kunis
In Forgetting Sarah Marshall, Jason Segel
plays Peter Bretter who is, as you can probably
guess, trying to forget his old girlfriend,
Sarah Marshall.
"You know what she’s a plane jane and she
should go back to where she came from."
"That is the mother of my…"
Peter Bretter retreats to a resort where he
gets over Sarah with the help of a resort
staffer, played by Mila Kunis.
Initially, Kunis' character has to call him
Mr. Bretter but she just can’t seem to get
it right.
"Hello Mr. Brenner.
Mr. Brayton!
Brenner!
I said Bretter!
"You said Brenner."
Rob Riggle
In the real world, it's pretty absurd for
one grown man to stare down another grown
man and tell him that he's going to hurt him.
It's doubly absurd to have to do this with
a comedy legend like Will Ferrell.
"I'm gonna take this and drive it into your
temple.
Prepare yourself for a fight, a fight that's
coming."
"I don't want that."
Unlike Will Ferrell, we definitely want more.
Harrison Ford
The explosion of the first Death Star is supposed
to be a moment of triumph for Han Solo and
the rebel forces, followed by celebration
and exultations.
All that celebrating is supposed to be followed
by some lines, but Harrison Ford totally blanks
on what those lines are supposed to be.
(When you get your paycheck for Indiana Jones 5)
Eating your mic is definitely one way go rogue.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!